water
earth fire
air i almost always choose scissors but
i'm not even sure how that would beat
air or water how do you even make air
with your fist
am i avataring right long ago the four
nations lived together in harmony
then everything changed when the fire
nation attacked
but how does the fire nation even get
the upper hand i feel like you could
douse that [ __ ] out with some air nation
or bury it with some earth nation or
maybe drown
it with some water nation fire really
should be the chump nation of this group
also in what season does the rhythm
nation show up i've heard they
lend a hand to help your brother do the
best oh look
dark on gray on shadow on black on
silhouette on
i can't see a [ __ ] thing this
supposed live-action remake of mulan
looks animated as [ __ ]
how does disney keep getting away with
this the yu yan can pin a fly to a tree
from 100 yards away
without killing it is that like an
actual fly or like jeff goldblum
as the fly because i cannot watch him
die again conveniently calculated
communication carried by claw is
critically convenient
uh maybe it's safer if i go on foot yep
smart but maybe go ahead and take your
weapon with you no we haven't been able
to pick up the avatar's trail since the
storm
but if we continue heading northeast or
maybe just get a more detailed map you
might as well be trying to find him
using a globe
fill it with water
now you know what my brain does when
someone attempts to explain avatar to me
now it's just me and me old woman lives
alone with a cat cliche
what about my friends well all they need
is some frozen wood frogs
there's plenty of them down in the
valley swamp you couldn't have said that
when aang first arrived what an asshag
what am i supposed to do with frozen
frogs well i suck on them of course
this reminds me of an old joke how do
you eat a frog you put a leg on each
cheek
never could quite figure that out since
i thought the legs were what everybody
liked and oh
now i get it a frog good working but i'm
a little confused the potion lady said
to not let the frogs fall out or they
would be useless which would mean the
water itself keeps them frozen so
why isn't ang currently in the process
of freezing he is in the water
hang what in the world is taking you so
long
um i'd be a little less concerned about
aang and a little more concerned about
the dead rat still laying on your chest
having a hard time buying that he could
cut through metal that cleanly and that
even if he could he wouldn't have taken
at least one of aang's appendages off
with them so let's give a send for each
hand and leg that are still attached
my frogs come back my friends need to
suck on those frogs
sure liang is smarter than this he's
screaming out for all to hear when he
knows there are more frogs in the frozen
frog river of convenience
escape and get more frogs yeah dumb yes
it's a good thing those super efficient
archers are suddenly replaced by a small
army of lame javelin
throwers hang is blasting the enemies
but somehow zuko stays on his feet and
holds on to his weapons i just don't
think that aang can be
that precise with his windy powers and
don't you come at me with that wind
envelope
again this is ridiculous i sort of love
it no i will not cave in and give a sin
back this time for a
wicked epic escape sequence all right
fine but only this one time
adorable city counter you do you have a
clear shot
oh now the archers show up frog
aside i'm just going to pretend he had a
frog shoot i am
how was your [ __ ] yesterday saka had no
idea who aang was but two seconds after
sucking on a frog he suddenly remembers
him i wonder what i'll remember after
licking this toad i found in the woods
i'll keep you updated
they spit out the frogs in yada yada
funny ending but where did all that momo
loot wind up that creature can haul
treasure and then put it all away but
not find water ridiculous
are you okay i'm fine i just uh
threw up in my mouth a little bit people
be like how is there a comment on the
video when it just posted
fans be like i'm a member motherfu you
could be a [ __ ] member too get
videos early extra videos bonus podcasts
swag discounts and more click the
patreon link in the description or at
cinemasins.com to take your sin to the
next level
shall i cough on you george no cold i'm
cold
so cold though he tried to be good he
[Music]
never
[Music]
i'll take over and rule the empire
who are you who are you people do you
have a clear shot
take the shot i say take the shot